hello there before we crack on with this
one I thought I should just let you know
that we started a second channel last
week and you should click here to
subscribe and definitely watch the first
video on the channel down gets wet and
now we'll crack on with the flamethrower
where he gets the opposite of wet hello
there the Internet
I'm keV you may immediately be wondering
where's dan why am i holding a fire
extinguisher here's the answer to both
questions yes kids this is a
flamethrower and if you can't tell I've
got a huge grin under this I can tell
you can tell I can see it your eyes are
they were like squash tonight yeah got
green eyes all right cool excellent yeah
say thanks to X matter for this personal
flames bro they're doing it and but by
the way first time I've ever received a
flamethrower in the post ice on my first
day no no happen once before just one of
those or more and it can hold 12 gallon
Bhavana only is so you could just
drowned Roger Rabbit in that it's quite
pretty color it's nice innit don't slice
didn't realize that diesel was a green
or green yeah
I'm really hi Missy
yeah I think I'm about to get hotter
sounds like it stop flipping it things
are about to heat up in here
for school down
we
if you think that looked like it would
be the most fun you've ever had in your
life then you're wrong it's more fun
than that
it's much more fun than the most fun you
can have in your life I'm not the most
intelligent bloke look on this level
guys any guess fossil is possible I had
a really good time filming that except
when I was downwind from it and it was
coming right yeah I had a great time for
it to be fair because I'm wearing short
no no yeah
all I could see was just I was aiming at
you all right here we go
find it and it was just a big wall of
flame and then I was like I should have
just egged it while the fly ball is up
somewhat it cleared there would just be
no one there I think I'd just been like
sweet Caravan fighter yes hopefully you
enjoyed that video feel free to follow
us on twitter and buy a shirt and most
importantly of all subscribe to the slow
mo guys channel and then tell every
single person you know i all like 300
people three alright i don't think i
know 300 people so i think you've got
like six friends maybe but i like six
good friends but i knew i know some
people have acquaintances no no no way
are we friends i'm one of the six i
think you wanted to say means you've got
five other friends
haha alright we'll see you in the next
video thanks audible for sponsoring this
video
they've got over 180,000 audio books
available and things like
autobiographies to Game of Thrones by
George RR martin which I'm currently
relisting to and reliving as you can see
getting ready for the new season if you
like the sure you'd love listening to
the books there's more characters what
you know I'm second half there's more
storylines it's really involving this
and basically it's fantastic if you'd
like a free trial at audible to spoil
the link in description below
audible.com for / slo-mo and you're set
but not for that for the north Oh
you